[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to this the very first
episode of night city wire the brand new
series from us at CD Projekt RED will
we'll be talking about all things
cyberpunk 2077
but today's episode will be starting
with a brand new trailer one of our
developers will be joining us to help
unpack everything you're going to see
we'll have some news an announcement
about a secret collaboration we'll be
taking a look at some brain dansgame
play and welcoming back our developers
just to have a chat about everything
you're going to see but there is one
more thing media all over the world have
been getting hands-on with cyberpunk
2077 and when this episode finishes
you'll be able to go and check out
exactly what they thought so let's get
started it is time to take a look at our
brand new trailer and after that I'll
lead quest designer papal Fastow will be
joining us because I've got a feeling
you're gonna have a few questions after
watching this so let's take a look city
of endless opportunity ready to get your
cherry popped come on like any other
is bigger
not just any other city legends are born
here
nature weeks rolling here cos Dex on the
strings doubt that puts cease and we
lose them but we are they just don't
know it yet
but if you got the cojones and you know
how to use them you could do damn near
anything unless you catch it ball even
then you go on with the bag right you
know you can make heaps more a
motivational speaker yo mr. V a pleasure
so what's the game Dex
you need to come out in one piece how
about we go over the plan there's this
prototype tech bio chip to be precise
dr. Graf esna belongs to a court arasaka
may Robbie some heavy hitters but you
can blackmail me [ __ ]
how is have a war first rule of the
afterlife to cut king baby
goes without saying we do this on the
hush I deal in nobody not a one
it sounds simple enough
is it gonna be dangerous don't you worry
we're bulletproof
what the [ __ ] is popping in there it
stopped digging nice you [ __ ] happy
now Jackie
[Applause]
[Music]
Thanks
what the [ __ ] gamers could be and you
who are you
[ __ ] so the trailer contains footage
from the games prologue only but there
was an awful lot in it so Pavel why
don't you try and help us unpack
everything that we just saw oh yeah I
mean absolutely I can try so would you
have just seen it's only the prologue of
the game so the awesome stuff is only
happening in the first few quests what
the trailer show you who is really our
stage the night CT you know this
gigantic city build of six completely
unique districts surrounded by the
seventh one that we call the badlands as
a player you are meeting
Jackie Jackie's your friend now they
together are trying to reach out for
something that is very precious they
were trying to reach out for this chip
of immortality this gateway to eternal
life Jackie introduces you to fixer
Dexter DeSean he's a very important
person in a social ladder of cyberpunk
he is able to provide the player with
various jobs and contracts to be able to
gather money to be able to modify their
bodies push themselves to the limits to
put their hands on a chip but as you can
expect not everything goes as planned
and but to to see it you will have to
play the game there are an awful lot of
really cool things in this trailer and
there's a few that I would just love to
talk about a little bit more for the
people at home so let's start with
talking about a gang called the mocks
now we see a few flashes of them in this
trailer I personally think they're
really cool on one of my favorites but
can you give us a little bit more
information about them oh yes so the box
is one of the gangs that player is going
to interact with throughout the game the
box is the gang that has been formed in
2076
after death of
Borden she was called lazy now she was
an owner of a brothel and former sex
worker and she was protecting working
guys and girls from harassment from
abuse and the gang is really continuing
her mission and as a player you are
going to interact with that gang meet
multiple different NPCs and craft your
own relationship with them and
understand what they are all about so
earlier on you did mention a seventh
district a place called the badlands now
we saw a few shots of this in the
trailer but I'd love for you to give us
a bit more detail about the district
outside of the city walls okay so the
badlands is this like dead dried-out
space going around the whole night city
and as a player you'll be able to
traverse that space in your car and
motorcycle this is a space that is
inhabited by the nomads no matter living
in a different families and they're
traveling across that space in convoys
made out of the cars and motorcycles and
as a player you'll be able to traverse
an axis a different type of open-world
content that has been prepared
specifically for you to that get that
awesome feel of the badlands as an area
in the trailer we also saw like a
completely metal creature now he didn't
look like he was from the Maelstrom gang
this looked like something else so this
other people at home who is this giant
metal monster okay so so the big dude
that was atom smasher he has been
introduced in a pen and paper in
cyberpunk 2020 by our senpai Mike bond
Smith atom smasher is a fully converted
cyborg he is who was always a loyalist
of arasaka
and time has changed and in 2077 he had
to find his own space in night city but
to find out you have to play the game in
this trailer we do see some flashes of a
ripper doc call Victor vector I think if
people have watched our previous
gameplays they might remember him but
I'd really like for you to give the
people at home some more information
about what Ripper Doc's are and how
they'll be interacting with them when
they play cyberpunk
so we products in our game they are
surgeons they are like a specific type
of a job in the social ladder of
cyberpunk
they are accustomed and specialized in
replacing limps to the metal ones they
can basically update your body enhance
your body change you into this walking
war machine and as a player you are
going to meet different kind of
reproduction in the game craft your own
relationship with them some of them are
like important characters for a for a
story to that you will invest Eddie's
that you're gathering to turn your body
into this tool that allows you to
survive on the streets of nights each
night
Pavel thank you so much for joining us I
know you'll be back later in the episode
because you're gonna be helping us to
analyze the brain dansgame play but
before that we do have some news to
share earlier in the year we announced
that if you pick up cyberpunk 2077 on
Xbox one you'll be able to play it on
Xbox series X when the console launches
and just in case you missed it it will
be the same for PlayStation players as
well if you pick up cyberpunk 2077 on
PlayStation 4 you'll also be able to
play it on PlayStation 5 when the
console launches and that's not all
there will be a free upgrade for Xbox
series X and Playstation 5 but we'll
have more details on that soon tonight
city before we reveal our first look at
the brain dansgame play and welcome back
our developers for a chat there is just
one more thing we want to announce
something that we've been working on in
secret for a while we are very excited
to announce our partnership with studio
trigger and network to bring you
cyberpunk edge runners a standalone
anime set in the cyberpunk universe
which we've been working on for some
time now edge runners is due to launch
in 2022 but for some more information
let's go to the team in Tokyo
[Music]
hey my name is saya elder I am the Japan
based producer for cyberpunk edge
runners what I do basically on this
project is that I am a fixer to put it
in the words of the cyberpunk universe
we are a game company we are a bunch of
nerds and wherever there are nerds
there's gonna be Ani made fans so it's
was always a dream for us to make on
eBay when we began this project we were
certain that we didn't want to make a
recreation of the game
cyberpunk edge runners is a standalone
story set in the same universe the stage
is still night city but everything else
is totally new new characters new story
I do like to think that it's going to be
a great gateway for newcomers to come
and check cyberpunk game and also the
cyberpunk genre as a whole
right now we're in Nakano which is one
of the biggest anime mecca's of the
world I'm gonna take you to studio
trigger right now because we have the
wonderful opportunity to talk to the
dream team that will be bringing you
this anime Conejo toreano to smolyak
know what cyclists can't ignore you
might say this character didn't your
turn to through your status
he gave me no cyberpunk no the conquer
has you made a good advocate on your
Neiman's okay state that Acadiana me
looks good as well yes you're a Spanish
mas congressman cyberpunk to you who
Clara g-dragon hyung sik up to Coronel
emeritus on dude hey so you don't know
what it's like a ransom state it's good
it to you know you meet Thomas Wheaties
to D go home
junetta today come to me he much
kilocalorie like me personally to Oregon
side corner which in there Tory got to
Shannon Sashi Cikini state title -
Thomas really
[Music]
now it's time to show you some gameplay
of brain dance this is a feature that
you'll experience when you play
cyberpunk 2077 brain dance is
essentially a recording of somebody
else's experience it allows you to
relive their sense of sight smell touch
and even hearing all thanks to a special
device after the gameplay I will be
welcoming back pal Sasuke I will also be
joined by Patrick Mills our senior quest
designer and all-round law master who
will be helping to answer your questions
and give you some explanation on how
you'll be interacting with brain dance
when you play cyberpunk 2077 so let's
take a look
plan simple do nothing odd don't get
creative you go in snatch the cash get
out and we sell the Biddy to go psycho
freak store studio got it got it and
remember everything on full blast don't
spot us extra for a wicked at running
the night
okay on you go
down everybody on the ground what I see
you kissing the flooring money now swear
I will [ __ ] drop you I swear to God
well yeah yeah now before I blow your
[ __ ] head off
ah slow deep breaths your cortisol and
adrenaline spikes but the soft activated
your hormone blockers nothing happened
you're alive and well
it was too much felt could feel the
guy's pain his dress his hope hope
wrapped up in something else
mmm-hmm Bradley took a booster just
before you'll be fine got everything set
up let's switch over to editing mode
I'll sever the link to the BD rollers
sensory array you'll be able to look
around freely
we'll see yours full cam control and
analysis mode so move around zoom in and
out whatever else you come up with think
of it as your own little sandbox so
analysis mode you control playback can
even pause when you feel the need then
you use the editor console to unpause
try it planned simple do nothing odd
don't get creative you go in snatch the
cash get out and we sell the BD to those
psycho freaks from Studio gotta got it
dream is hell right well that's not all
you can speed things up or rewind
whatever you like give it a try
rewind roll it back to the top good now
try fast-forwarding a bit
plan simple okay you can also reset the
recording that'll take you right back to
the beginning try it
now for some fun this here's why you
came in the first place in analysis mode
you get to you and even scan details of
the enviro recorded by the beady roller
focus on the heat the gun this gunk gets
from his buddy at the beginning now
scanning plan simple do nothing odd
don't get creative you go in snatch the
cash okay right here
excellent let's move on now heads up in
analysis mode you can ferret out
background noise and conversations if
the roller got close enough this track
records everything every little detail
even the sights and sounds the roller
was never aware of to see the sources of
the recorded sensory signals switch to
the audio layer in the editor go ahead
and try that now okay good
now you should see several sound
signatures in the store choose one and
holding on it
kind of six case of broseph and a couple
of summers okay we have a deal today on
true flavors Cody
everybody so any thoughts unbelievable
seriously like what's happening right
next to me
it's how BD recording implants work they
pick up everything all the elements in
the background then editor tweaks makes
them pop keep playing with the sound
explore it a bit we'll move on when you
get bored
what our saviors in the flooring money
yes sometimes you can analyze extra
layers and the raw stuff the rollers
fiber we're picked up like what Ed's got
Karoshi optics that grab infrared
meaning you should be able to grab a
heat signatures from her recording huh
hello nice scanning works on peeps to
walk up to the wounded chick try
scanning her alright next thing scroll
forward to the part where our artist
gets a med injection
see that they shot him and he never saw
it coming but you will hear it comes my
favorite part of the game see the
blinking thing over the entrance
surveillance cam must have caught our
shooter you'll see in a sec cam feeds to
the screen behind the clerk roll back to
where the screams and the kids field of
vision then scan it
his own tune by Charlaine probably
planned to all along must have got a
nice LASIK read on the black market for
a BD like this
BD freaks are ready to pay a premium for
real flatline anyway if you've seen
enough you can exit yeah too bad most of
the biddies we do here are only good for
flogging relog so brain balance is a
pretty big part that the cyberpunk
universe it's not just something used
for adult films there is an awful lot to
it and there's two sides
I'd really like you guys to help me
explore first is the law so how this
actually fits into the universe and then
there's the gameplay side so how players
will be interacting with it so Patrick
could you tell us more about the law of
rain dance
I would love to so in the world of
cyberpunk 2077 brain dance was invented
way back in the early 2000s at UC Santa
Cruz it was developed as a way of
recording a person's experiences and
then playing them back for someone else
as so that they could relive them as
though it was happening to them it was
originally used for things like therapy
and prisoner rehabilitation but by 2077
it's become this global media industry
including things like movies massive
mass entertainment things like that
video games some interactive things and
of course adult fare as well now in our
game we deal a lot with black brain
dances or X biddies as we call them and
there are different types of those but
the one that you saw in the trailer just
there was a flat liner now that's where
the person recording it
you
I'm thrill but a mercenary can also use
them for various things and you'll see
that in the game of course and from the
gameplay perspective we have been
working a lot throughout last year's
trying to figure out the best way how to
use the brain dance in the game as a
mechanics so what we have settled on is
this
Brandon's editor mode as a player you
will be able to run the Brandon's in the
editor mode and see different clues that
have been registered on the peripheral
of given actor now as a player you can
slide on a timeline of the recording
back and forth trying to uncover
different clues and that clues are
actually telling a story in the game so
as a player you will run different
investigations that will lead you to
different mysteries and you will uncover
them actually using the brain dance as a
mechanics in the game so as Pavel was
saying we use brain dance as a
storytelling tool it's not a collectible
it's not something where you're going to
go in and you're gonna play it and
you're gonna be like I've seen this
before what we use brain dance for is to
give you a keyhole into the life of the
residents of night City and we can
explore things like childhood trauma
religion various philosophical ideas in
a way that you might not otherwise
experience in a story about a mercenary
on the tough streets so we've tried to
talk about some of the aspects that we
think the community will find really
exciting but you know while you're both
here I'd love to know what is it about
cyberpunk that you guys are really
excited for Patrick why don't you start
so one of the things that I'm most
excited about in this game is the
characters and the way they interact
with the world we've got this really
interesting world that stretches all the
way back to the cyberpunk 2020 source
material and all of these events and all
those things but those don't mean
anything unless they connect with
characters and so when we come up with a
character we start with their function
what is this person what do they do in
this story but we don't stop there we go
back and we figure out what was their
childhood like what was their upbringing
like what kind of obstacles did they
face in this harsh reality and did they
overcome them and how did they overcome
them or did they not overcome them and
why
and you can see all of those things in
their environment in their dialogues in
sort of how they operate in the world
and we come up with up for all of our
characters now you look at someone like
Victor vector and you're gonna see
stories about his past in his
environment and in his dialogue you know
we come up with that stuff even if we
don't use it in the game because it
helps inform us as to who these
characters are and for me I would not be
myself if I would not say that I'm the
most excited about our quests like
without witcher 3 team with with patrick
and like everybody that has stay with us
since the witcher 3 time we really have
grown so much we have learned so much
and we have used all that experience to
put them into the quests that we have
made and you will not find really a
filler in this game like everything has
a meaning like we put so much effort
into making sure that everything is
rewarding he's interesting is talking
about characters as patrick said it's
talking about worlds it's talking about
emotions like touching the player and
they're really like a real way and i
just can't wait to find out what you
think pavel I know you mentioned story
and quests and writing quests and when I
was last in the studio I had a look and
I saw a notebook on your desk and I
would love for you to show everybody
this notebook you ask for it so this is
a my notebook
it's a Southwest designer the reason is
because I dance salsa and I'm a quest
designer so I wrote started this
notebook actually when we were really
starting cyberpunk at the very beginning
I wrote in like a first note and it says
pretty much something along the lines of
it that we were starting with a
prototype and then you know I kept on
the basically noting things that we've
been working on for like next years I
remember once when our concept artists
actually approached me and they said
that they want to take a look at my
notebook I was like what for actually
and they took some pictures and they
told me yeah well you know because we
are looking for a reference material for
notes of a psychopathic killer so so
yeah well that you may find me
some of my notes in the game Pavel and
Patrick thank you so much for joining me
I'm pretty lucky because I have read
some of the stories that you and the
team have written for brain dance and
I'm pretty excited for people to
discover them but before we do finish
today's episode there is just one more
thing we'd like to talk about earlier in
this episode I mentioned that media have
been getting hands-on with opening of
cyberpunk 2077 and they should be
posting their impressions right about
now and if you missed anything from
today's episode don't worry we'll be
uploading everything to our channels
very soon
and finally on behalf of everybody at CD
Projekt RED we just want to say thank
you so much for joining us for this the
very first episode of night city wire
but don't worry we'll be back with
episode 2 in just a few weeks so we
shall see you soon
[Music]
one I'm just gonna get right into it
because now you guys are free to talk
about actually playing cyberpunk take do
you want to take it away Jake what what
from that presentation had you already
seen so I hadn't seen a lot of that in
my playthrough because I was kind of
messing around so I just explored Knight
city I was messing around with NPCs the
environment and whatnot however I did
see a lot of that in some b-roll they
had sent over so I was very familiar
with what we saw for the most part there
was a lot of there was a lot of other
stuff in there but like I guess just top
level impressions based on what I played
it seems like a I I hate comparing it to
things but it reminded me a lot of GTA
but with very heavy RPG elements just in
like how it felt walking around this
giant city with pedestrians walking
around in the way you'd hop in a car and
you could switch the third third-person
mode and drive around the city going to
different objectives but the big thing
that really stood out to me that I'm
really excited to see more of is just
how dense and populated the city is and
how and how much detail there is there
like I spent so much time just like I
had a I had a developer with me and he I
could not just follow one path I Drive I
don't know probably like 20 meters and
I'd be like oh and I'd hop out of my car
and I'd check out a little side alley
and it would open up into this big
marketplace where there'd be tons of
characters walking around and there
would be music blaring and the
advertisements kind of overwhelming but
in a good way in a way that you that
probably should be the case in a
cyberpunk
world but man yeah top level stuff it is
it reminded me a lot of like a GTA RPG
so where did you actually like what part
of the game did you actually play Sam
so in our demo we playthrough we got to
pick between one of the starting life
paths there's three there's corpo
there is street kid and then there's
nomad and we have an impressionist video
coming up later on you should see it on
YouTube and guess what'll come where
myself Jake and Ed talk about each of
those paths and the three divergent
styles that we played but we each got to
start the game at the very beginning
pick a life path which is an origin
story think of it in the same way that
you would in Dragon Age you pick a you
know a starting point for your character
and then you were basically left to do
what you wanted to do from the outset of
the game so it's a very beginning of the
game in my playthrough I decided to
follow the main quest for a little bit
and see where that takes me
and for the most part was being for be
quite similar to last year's gameplay
demo where you do the opening mission
where you go to the apartment and rescue
the lady in the bathtub and kind of turn
her over to the trauma team to take care
of and then you go you meet Dexter
DeSean and then you start doing the kind
of Maelstrom mission to get the the AI
controlled or mind controlled turret
back and it kind of escalates from that
point and from that point on it kind of
branches off into a smaller other you
can do side quests or you can do things
that are still tied to their main quest
but I like the the main crux of the area
the point the part I was in was a heist
good to go into a certain person's home
or office and steal a certain things and
there's a lot of setup to getting that
done and part of that self is the brain
dance so before we move on to the brain
dance I have a couple more questions
about sorry my um Jake you were saying
that you know you can really go more
than 20 meters that kind of being
distracted and wanting to see something
new what's there to keep pushing you to
continue the main story or are you just
free to do whatever you want in this
world so I mean after you pick your
origin story at the beginning I went
with nomad which started me out in the
badlands
after you complete that and you get
tonight city there's like a time skip
which we didn't get to see what happens
in between they said there's gonna be a
cinematic or some sort of thing prepared
that'll go over all that kind of stuff
we didn't get to see that they just put
a
right into night city where you do a I
believe you do another quest and then
from then on you go back to your
apartment and it just kind of opens up
your directive is to go to talk to
Jackie because he's he's talking to
Dexter to Shawn about a job however I
didn't really do that immediately I
walked out of the I walked out of my
apartment went to a shop bought a knife
walked down and stabbed a knight City PD
just in the back to see what would
happen and the the whole crowd started
panicking and people started freaking
out but then from there I just kind of
went in my own direction I really only
explored one of the major districts I
think I saw bits and pieces of other
ones
but I was mostly in I want to say maybe
the city center I forget exactly what
district I was in but yeah like to stay
there is like that dotted line two
different objectives and you can track
quest just like you couldn't The Witcher
but like I said there was so much both
showing up on my map that were like
distracting not in a bad way but I was
just like ooh this seems interesting and
then there was also other things in the
environment that just stood out that I
was like I have to see what this is
about
oh yeah I mean like you're saying it's a
very dense world but it looks like time
I'm gonna ask you a little bit about
gameplay-wise what did it actually feel
like to walk around in and how did they
actually and also combat have that so I
think like to walk around in its it's
quite I think they're the kind of crux
of my preview that is now live on the
site was everything felt kind of
overwhelming and like Jake said earlier
overwhelming in the right way there was
so much to it felt like it reminded me
of being in Tokyo for the first time
where it felt familiar like the building
blocks of the city were things that
you've seen before but the sense of just
stimulus coming from literally every
direction it kind of makes your nerve
sting a little bit and that's where that
sense of like losing not losing focus
but not sure where to put your focus
happens and so like it felt like a
futuristic metropolis
you know metropolitan might replace
where your where your just trying to
make your way around and you could like
walk around for hours probably and just
kind of drink it in and see what happens
unfortunately we didn't really have
hours to do that so it's just a little
bit of walking around and there's it is
a bustling seat you have a lot to stare
at and interact with and listen to and
but the actual gameplay and the shooting
was the kind of main thing that I
suspect not Specht into but like ended
up doing and it felt really really
satisfying even so that either one of
the things I mentioned in my preview is
I struggle with games that are like RPG
shooters Lou issue as whatever you want
to call him not a lot of them always hit
for me like feeling good and feeling
satisfying because you're chipping away
a healthier you know you're shooting at
shields that kind of stuff and although
you are kind of doing that this feels
like it still is satisfying to do like a
game like Borderlands I mentioned in my
preview is one that doesn't quite work
for me in the same way like a destiny
would because Destiny's guns feel
impactful
whereas Borderlands guns are cool and
quirky but they don't always have that
that kind of satisfying conscience to
them this is a game where the guns have
a satisfying punch to them when they
need to obviously there are guns that
feel a little lighter and more alive but
for the most part everything felt good
to shoot and it felt good to like shoot
at things even if that meant you were
you were kind of like shooting at
shields or chipping away at health at
the same time there was a lot of
opportunity to play in other ways like I
did stealth stuff and it felt very very
viable and I like I said previously I'm
a stealth person and this game does that
really great thing of when you do a
thing it rewards you for doing the thing
so if you're crouching around and
walking around it gives you experience
for doing that if you're shooting loads
of rifles it gives you experience for
shooting those rifles if you're hacking
loads it gives you experience for being
a hacker on top of allowing you to spec
into it so like that at the start of
this kind of answer I mentioned
overwhelming and it's the same for the
gameplay as well there's so much you can
think about there's so much for you to
think about there's so much for you to
keep in mind and spec into and
and that kind of stuff it just feels
like a a a like meaty game to play Jake
how did you find it yeah I mean I'd say
very similar to tomorrow I played is
kind of like gay I tried to play as a
net runner but because I was still very
early in the game I didn't have a lot of
abilities I only was able to hack a
couple things and a couple characters
which was a lot of fun like a hacking
minigame pops up and I actually had a
lot of fun playing the hacking minigame
to the point where I like wanted to hack
more just because I had fun matching the
numbers but as a I don't know I guess I
early netrunner I was mostly watching a
lot of these experience these hacking
things so I would try to hack and maybe
hack a couple things and then someone
would catch my scent and then I'd go
guns blazing and it was a lot of
shooting which I which I was cool with
because that's something that's a way
that I will probably end up playing I
did notice like now we played a preview
build and early build so it's not done
but the shooting didn't feel as precise
as something like this near Call of Duty
however kind of like Tamar was saying
like the shooting still felt very
satisfying and I think a lot of that is
due to the fact that these guns kick
like a donkey and the the sound effects
are really good like it just feels
really satisfying to shoot things even
like I used the smaller pistol a lot
because my pistol skill was getting high
and I had fun using the pistol and even
that like it sure was a small dinky
little pistol but it really did feel
like I I was like packing iron I was
ready to go so that was great and then I
was noticed a we played on controller
they didn't want us to use mouse and
keyboard so we played controller and I
did notice there was a pretty generous
aim-assist
I don't know how much you'll be able to
eat when the the final game comes out
but yeah I was gonna say that we didn't
play on mouse and keyboard mainly we
should say we we the the reason we
played with the controller is because we
used we played through the cloud using a
special kind of bit of software and that
meant that we weren't able to engage
with
the mouse and keyboard it wasn't a
technical limitation or anything like
that
you're just a matter of the software
would get confused if we were both
trying to import at the same time using
math and kiki mouse and keyboard and
controller yeah and and so that was the
reason we played on controller but like
Jake said the controller soft felt fine
it felt good you know a shooting with
with a it was it had that good sense of
feedback on a controller that you get
which is the same you know on whether
you're playing with mouse and keyboard
or controller but yeah I think those who
want to play on master keyboard or those
people that want to play on controller
should be well taken care of so one
thing I was gonna ask obviously the game
is still in development you are playing
through the cloud so it's not exactly
apples to apples when you're playing it
at home and it's the final product but
how did it run Jake so it ran pretty
smooth for me for the most part in terms
of just like frame rate and all that
stuff there were some crowded areas
where it would dip a little bit but you
know once again we kind of trust that
that stuff will be worked out when the
game comes out and they did delay it I
did run into bugs I did run into a good
amount of bugs nothing game-breaking but
there were definitely some bugs here and
there some funny ones that that happened
I mean you know with games this big that
kind of stuff is bound to happen like
there's somebody I guess funny bugs in
The Witcher and whatnot
but once again you know it's kind of
hard to say what the final release would
be like because they did just delay it
and they said mostly to squash bugs but
overall like I mean streaming it on PC I
have pretty good internet so it works
pretty well in that sense I didn't have
any latency or lag or anything like that
but the game itself seemed to run pretty
well from what I could tell I'm
definitely excited to you know when I
play this on PC to really dig into all
those settings and see how far we'll be
able to push this game before we dig
into what we saw in night city wire are
there any final comments about your time
your hands on time I'll time I'll go to
you first yeah I think I think the thing
that I walked away from playing it was I
just had seen a fraction
and it sounds very much like what they
say in the night CT wire this is just a
small piece of it but it really does
feel like it was a very very small piece
of the game we played for four hours and
I still kind of my mind was racing with
wanting to do ten different things at
the same time and you know there's so
many paths that you can take I wanted to
stop and try something reloaded and
start again but I wasn't able to but I
think the thing that I'm most excited
about is when people do get their hands
on the game it looks like there's gonna
be plenty for us to really dissect and
think about and talk about so that's the
most exciting thing about it for me
right now Jake what about you yes so
there's two things that I do wanna
mention the first is it there's pubic
hair customization and that out in the
character critic could we start out by
doing that which is something that I
like had the double take I was like I
don't know if I actually saw that and
then Edie was talking about it too I was
like okay I did actually see a pubic
hair option I didn't mess with most of
the customization options just because I
didn't want to spend too much time in
the character creator I wanted to get in
and play and then the other thing I want
to mention is that V has like one thing
I noticed that the V has like a phone
essentially I mean it's not called the
phone in the cyberpunk universe I forget
what it's called but they get messages
and whatnot and I'm curious to see what
kind of role that will play because I
was getting messages as I played and I
checked those and a lot of times it
would be like hey we've got a job for
you which which would lead to a quest
which I could track right then and there
but I'm also curious to see how that
will work with characters because there
was some I could respond to like I
didn't pick what I wanted to say it was
just a predetermined thing I just hit
respond and then V would write something
and send but I'm curious to see like if
that will come into play in a sense like
it like GTA 4 did almost or like your
buddies would be like hey do you want to
hang out do want to go to a bar or
whatnot because that is something that
this game seems to have a lot of is like
what you do when you're not killing
people how you blow off steam and
whatnot so I'm very curious to see how
that's gonna tie into the very different
relationships and characters you meet
throughout the game because personally I
love that stuff in games and there's
a little phone and you've got your side
conversations going on my god I hope
there is a reference where some
character asks if you want to go bowling
in that case mm-hmm it's gotta be all
right so let's talk a little bit about
what we saw in night fifty wire so we
had some more details from pawel sass
co-lead quest designer I talked a little
bit about districts we got to see the
7th district is called the badlands big
kind of Mad Max vibes they're very cool
I need to I need to talk about this guy
atom smasher absolute like I was sad
that there was no Keanu Reeves
but it's behind atom smasher what a
great day
what were the highlighted section before
we start talking about edge runners yeah
the atom smasher thing is actually
interesting because it kind of feeds
into the brain down stuff I'm interested
to see how that character carries on or
appears in that game during the section
that they show him walking towards a
elevator you are actually in a brain
dance at that time and the person who is
seeing atom smasher actually gets scared
and when you're reliving that brain
dance as V you feel that fear which is
an interesting kind of layered thing so
when this happens in the game the
character you're you're inhabiting is a
woman and you can feel her or they
through the presentation show that she's
scared and then that feeling of fear
lingers with V so there's an interesting
kind of like a lingering effect of what
you do and the emotions and the feelings
you have in a brain dance that kind of
can carry into the real life in the game
so we'll see what that means narrative
Lee and in terms of characterization for
V and doing these brain dances but yeah
that section is really really cool it's
it's it's like one of the things that we
talked about earlier an unexpected part
of the cyberpunk gameplay experience
the investigative stuff and and that
kind of business is something that I'm
super into so
I think that looks that I look really
cool yeah that's actually a very nice
segue into the brain dance segment I
mean I genuinely hadn't I deliberately
didn't speak to you guys about what
you'd seen just so that I would be kind
of fresh to it and I expected you to be
able to play those sequences I didn't
realize there would be that level of
detail where it is like a batman arkham
origins kind of the crime scene
investigation rewinding positioning
similar from arkham knight - that was
really really cool
i wondered like how much of the plot is
gonna be in these brain dance segments
jake did you get any indication not
really i actually didn't have a chance
to check out the rain dance sections
because i spent more time messing around
but one thing that ed said when we were
doing our impressions he said it remind
him a lot of tacoma
i don't know if you guys played that but
i can definitely see it watching the
gameplay and how you're basically
rewinding and replaying specific
sections and you're trying to key in on
specific items and figure out details
and you know you know i think it's kind
of neat to see that sort of system from
a very small indie game in this like
giant triple-a game now could they
necessarily not necessarily stole that
idea or you know - took reference from
it but it's just interesting to see this
actual this i was going to say this this
brain dance section is is a tutorial for
the actual gameplay mechanic and
involves these two characters holding up
the store and at the end of it the
person holding up the store dies and the
tutorial is a kind of investigation into
how this character or this the robber
gets killed because it's uncertain so
they use this as a it's a really
interesting little setup and they use
this as to teach the player about how
brain dances work and then they very
quickly become more elaborate from this
point on i got to do two during my
playthrough and this was the simpler of
the two
the other one was shortly after atom
smasher gives you the dirty look in
there what was that one like can you
describe it so that one was actually a
the atom smasher post atom smasher one
was a part of a heist that you are
planning for so the the whole point of a
brain dance is it like they said in the
in the actual gameplay demo it captures
a scene a memory and recreates it for
others to experience usually gets used
for pornography but certain characters
like Judy Alvarez I think her name was
she's able to edit them and recreate
them so you can relive them outside of
Pawnee reasons and so your as Vee you're
scouting out this this this apartment
because it belongs to the son of one of
the mega corporations that controls the
night see and this person has a special
piece of technology that you want to
steal and what you have to do is the
person you're living the the memory as
is someone that has a close relationship
with this this person let's call it and
you are reliving the memory so you can
investigate the room see what its layout
is try and figure out where the item you
wanna steal is placed listen to the
conversation maybe get an idea of what
his plans are and and kind of generally
build a foolproof heist before you
actually go in there and do it yourself
and it's really really interesting
because it was more elaborate than the
liquor store holdup one but it's still
quite maintained quite limited in in
kind of like how it played out the
character and would just move across the
room and you just kind of track him and
listen in on this conversation and then
you'd switch like a heat signature layer
and try and find out where the item is
is located because it needed to be super
cool so you're looking for the coldest
spot in the room so it was part of the
kind of like build up towards making a
more complex but I still hit that kind
of I'm an investigator and I'm figuring
something out
pleasure node in the brain that people
get out of these kind of experiences so
it was always fun
and it was intricate and interesting in
a way that you know is a nice refreshing
change of pace from the usual shooting
sneaking of the main game alright so I
think in terms of the first night city
wide presentation that wasn't you know a
Keanu moment
that wasn't a grimes moment there was an
anime moment so I'm gonna go to our
resident anime expert Jake what did you
think of the anime reveal I'll pass it
on to some more no I'm just kidding I
I'm very excited to see what this will
be
I will definitely watch it just because
I'm very into cyberpunk not super into
anime but we're seeing maybe maybe this
will change my mind I know studio
trigger like then doing this is a very
big deal and they have made some very
good anime but I couldn't tell you what
that is so I think I think tomorrow's
gonna have to teach us teach me a lesson
here I think we should clip the moment
where Jake says I'm very excited for
anime for analysis studio trigger one of
the most talented Animation Studios in
the world
definitely in Japan known for enemies
like kill Akio mainly and recently they
put out Pamir
in in in kind of cinemas and both
critically acclaimed they have other
stuff that they've done as well little
witch academia and and Gurren Lagann I
think was them as well and but they are
a fantastic animation studio they have a
very distinct style that works really
really well with kind of cyberpunk and
they they've been it's coming out in
2022 which means and everything that's
happening in here is a it's got its
takes place in night City and shares the
walls of cyberpunk for a unique story
unique characters which is incredibly
exciting they've shown off one teaser
image which is like a kid who looks like
a character out of killer killer Gurren
Lagann it's kind of peering over
shoulder and wearing the iconic jacket
and it looks awesome
I think the thing
kind of takes it to the next level is
the music is actually being done by
Akira Yamaoka who is the composer behind
Silent Hill and various entries in
Silent Hill franchise and just an
absolute like legend in the gaming
industry so the fact that we've got
studio trigger teaming up with a kiri
omocha to make a cyberpunk anime is
pretty exciting it's coming to Netflix
in 2022 which means we're probably be
done by the game by then so perfect
timing
all right that just about wraps it up
Jake any more final comments and what we
saw this morning or what you had hot
hands on with ah there was something
that I had in my head a while ago but I
forgot what it was that I wanted to say
welcome back move smoother smooth
genitals because I I went to the general
section as well and immediately you can
change your general size you can pick it
you know type or you can just get rid of
it so I did the smooth boy just to just
to see what was I liked and it was it's
absolutely fine no issues yeah the can
hold it you can you can pick your size
if you want to yeah I don't know if I
don't know if that it's gonna become
visible at any point my hope is that you
reckon you can hook up with people I I'm
I'm changing my run to a stealth no-kill
fully nude run so it's gonna be exciting
you can watch the stream of it on
twitch.tv folks flash games well that's
not happening by the way so no I'm fine
I've already put in my calendar come
back to you I mean one thing that that I
thought was pretty funny was the store
that I bought the knife from was called
second amendment I guess another thing
that was kind of cool was the the the
Nomad path started out in the badlands
and seeing that seeing what's outside of
night city it was really awesome and I'm
excited to check out the other life
paths and I guess the other thing too to
bring up is that we are going to be
doing a Q&A video next week so if you
have any questions for us about
cyberpunk and what we played make sure
to tweet it either myself tomorrow or
Edmund Tran because we're gonna get back
together and try to answer all the
questions that you guys might have keep
in mind that we did only play four hours
and it was very early in the game so we
didn't see a whole lot but there's still
a lot to talk about getting the band
back together so your Q&A all right
we're gonna we're gonna show the video
of your impressions so kind of more
in-depth chat about what you guys played
featuring all the new gameplay thank you
for joining us this morning and we'll be
back again next time there is a 960 wire
playful all streams we're doing charity
streams every day and we will see you
next time
hey everyone the three of us just played
four hours of cyberpunk eh we all pick
different life paths and we all played
slightly differently in this video we're
gonna go over what differences we
encountered during our play demo so
let's start with Edie so I went with
Coppa it starts off with you throwing up
in a sink and your initial story is
you're a counterintelligence operative
and your boss wants to sort of take down
his boss unfortunately the higher-ups
get wind of it and you end up getting
your life to basically like torn to
shreds like all of your money like all
of your like insurance your entire life
that's been supported by this corporate
job of yours is gone and you end up on
the street basically from starting from
scratch you already friends with your
partner Jacqui at this point and so he
kind of helps you out and helps you get
back on your feet and then two more you
picked the street rat the kid street kid
yeah and so my one I start off in a bar
and the street kid has got some
connections and it's like three mystery
wary and wily and is from night city or
treats they're like home and
one of the bartenders at the bar who's
got a ongoing debt towards one of the
fixes and he kind of asked you to go
speak to the fixer and try and help out
anna deavere or get his debt settled
entirely so you go and do that and you
have an argument with this fixer who's
an out-of-towner and you kind of throw
your weight around as a local he shows
you like there's a magazine and there's
a sports car on there and he's like
steal that a sports car it's top of the
line it'll clear the debt so you go over
you get point to the right direction by
his Inside Man and then you start
stealing and the moment you start
getting the car like this hand comes
through the window and tells you to get
out and obviously you kind of like pull
away and try to use the device the
device doesn't work you get pulled out
the car you're about to get beaten up
but in the cops shop and they kind of
put both of you to the ground and then
someone like an elite or one percenter
shows up and like it's not worth wasting
your time throw them both out so you get
chucked out on the street the person who
pulled you out of the car
was Jackie and he's like that that's how
you meet I was told there's a montage
that shows your progression through the
years it wasn't actually in our my demo
I'm not sure if it was any of yours but
effectively it's kind of like we were
told like a an animated sequence of some
sort or cinematic sequence that kind of
shows that you guys stuck together for a
while did a bunch of jobs you had a
history and then you pick up with the
main story yes so I played the Nomad
path and the Nomad path begins with your
character v tearing off the I don't know
the the badge of their clan and heading
in tonight city in order to smuggle
something into the city and your car
breaks down in this small town out way
outside of night city in this desert
town and you're trying to repair your
car you repair your car to meet your
contact who has the thing that you're
trying to smuggle in it turns out to be
Jackie you meet him talk with him a
little bit and then you and Jackie head
to the border where you have to get out
of the car and they do an inspection and
you have to talk to a I guess a border
agent I would say and they ask you some
questions hop back in the car and then
as you're driving there's a roadblock
that they'd set up and then there's a
firefight that happens and eventually
that section ends and then apparently
we'd get the cutscene too that would
lead you into how the game starts and
then once you've done those
introductions it sounds like the game
for the most part is very similar like
all three paths kind of merged now sit
out and tell me what's good for short
it's good see you jack how you been so
with that out of the way how did you
guys play I I like to spec into like
handguns specifically handguns and melee
and stealth and I found that I ended up
relying on my handgun a lot because
given that this is so early in the game
a lot of the stealth skills that are
actually useful unavailable to you
unless you unlock them with perks so I
found myself failing stealth a lot and
ending up in a lot of firefights yes I I
put together one of the classic like I
don't know what I'm doing trash Bill's
where I like I was just like oh how do I
usually play and I I didn't learn the
lesson that had clearly did very quickly
so obviously it is always smaller than
me like I did the thing where I expect
into stealth and SPECT into cool and
body so I was like I can be sneaky and I
can talk my way out of things and have a
bit of charisma obviously didn't think
about the fact that it will take a while
for that to come into full effect so
ended up being a kind of a run-and-gun
kick the door in type person who is
clearly incapable of doing it because
I'm spec towards snow so I created like
a bumbling idiot over V but it's still
what it did lock me out of anything I
was still quite capable like in
firefights I was winning it's fun to
note that if you do pick up something
that's not in your wheelhouse you can
still get better at it by just doing the
thing so if if I like I didn't have any
shotgun skills at all but I picked up a
shotgun inside shooting at a bunch you
would rank up with the gun and yeah it's
it's kind of like Skyrim where the thing
you do you get better out it's funny you
mentioned the cool thing because when I
created my character I dumped all my
points into cool right away and the
person I was playing with the dev was
like may not want to do that and I was
like okay and I was like well what if I
want to play like a net runner so he had
me spec into intelligence and I think
technical ability was what it was called
but what I found out too is cool is
connected to stealth and I ended up
using a lot of stealth because kind of
like your guys experience I ended up
being trash in net running just because
I didn't really have many abilities
unlocked and I and I imagine that's
gonna be a similar sort of experience
for most people who start this game
maybe not so much using fire
but I think you're gonna spec into
something and then as you play you're
gonna figure out how you actually want
to play at least early on it's important
to note that we played the first four or
five hours of the game of like what is
gonna be like a fifty sixty hour game so
a lot of the stuff that really will
matter in the end doesn't really come
into play so I can in the cool perk
system there's like a like a cold blood
like ability so when you like get super
cool you have like lost abilities and
that kind of stuff yeah I I the small
amounts of steps that I did manage to
pull off was quite interesting because
it was like a mixture of my stealth
movement and also using the net runner
stuff like hacking into a camera I I
didn't realize that when you hack into a
camera they're very threatening those
cameras because they fire a laser beam
laser and like a blankets the entire
thing and they move around and I was
like damn how do I even begin to do this
and I didn't realize that actually when
you hack into a camera you effectively
take it over and it's yours but it
doesn't change the red laser into green
to be like hey you agree now it's good
it's a good it's a good laser feel like
doing the small amounts of I'm sneaking
hacking that thing using it to distract
enemies the way like the two different
divergent styles of play kind of meshed
together was really interesting so I'm
looking forward to see how they can be
paired up with like you know net runners
ability hacking abilities with the
stealth and then stealth abilities kind
of complemented by the you know powerful
gun kind of like spec and that kind of
stuff that was the one thing almost
every encounter I started out by hacking
into the local network or whatever it
might be and once you do that you it
basically it highlights all the
different things you can hack which I
think because I was pretty early I
wasn't able to hack a lot but they were
like fans I could hack to distract
enemies there were cameras you could
hack you could hack certain NPCs to to
get other NPCs to come by you could hack
grenades to make them explode okay so
we've talked about place that we've
talked about origin how about how you
guys just kind of played this demo if
there was a lot we could do they didn't
really put any restrictions on us at all
in terms of what we could do so how did
you guys spend your four hours
my own was probably the most plain
playthrough and I jumped into it and
just kind of followed the main part and
quickly realized that it was a familiar
path I talked about this in my written
preview but it's it's the lot of it was
the missions that we saw in the gameplay
demos from the past two years obviously
this is the first time we've actually
played it for ourselves I think the
actual main path at least to start with
is a really good example of the
different facets of the gameplay
mechanics like that first mission you do
with four Dexter deshaun you get a good
flavor of what is hacking like what is
combat like what is sneaking like and
you can start to figure out
I like I've got a feel for the hacking I
really like that so I'm gonna expect
towards that and then I use the kind of
final moments to try and find some some
like side quests that were interesting
the side quests are what everyone loves
from Witcher so I wanted one of those at
least and I found that yeah I mean I
probably took the exact opposite
approach in that I didn't even really do
side quests I just roamed the world and
messed around like the first thing I did
when I got out of these apartment is I
took I bought a knife from the store
called 21st amendment and stabbed a cop
because I don't know he was out there I
want to see what would happen which is
something different from The Witcher 3
right because well a there's no cops but
also you can't just start destroying a
town in The Witcher right because Geralt
is this character who wouldn't do that
but in this you have that freedom I've
got a I forget how much the warrant was
and then it I got a notification saying
that the NCPD are now after me and that
was pretty interesting just because I
don't know immediately I thought of GTA
yeah like in that big GTA vibes coming
from this game you can also help the
cops to like you can go past like a
holdup or something and help them out
there are a lot of incidental things
happening in the city that you can just
join in on
in fact the incidental stuff remind me a
lot of Red Dead like you just be walking
around and there'd be a firefight
between cops and gangs and you could
help out one of the sides you just walk
away or sometimes there just be a bunch
of guys guarding a cache or something
and you could go in kill them take it or
occasionally with your when you get your
upgraded I I forget what they call it
grated vision you know you can actually
see if there's a warrant out on NPCs and
you can just examine them and if you see
or an out on this arrest for this amount
you can kill him and you'll
automatically get that money transferred
in your account I mentioned this to Jake
earlier but I was doing some of that
kind of exploring and found an incident
or thing which was gang fighting each
other a couple of gangs and I was like
I'm just gonna check this out in the
moment I realized I should probably get
all of my my actual quest is when one of
them threw a grenade at another one
another one and missed completely and
the grenade just landed at my feet and I
was like I am I am NOT here for this I'm
out after hearing about some other
experience I wanted to go see a lot more
side quests but I think given that this
is so early in the game and the game it
actually does want to put you through
those main quests to get you good
breadth of experience they weren't that
many other proper side missions that I
could do the side quests that I did find
did look at sort of the kookier nature
of like the cyberpunk world so one had
you get into like a Fight Club situation
with these twins who had merged their
consciousness to be one person and
there's a lot like funny banter between
them and like stuff about them sharing
girlfriends and that kind of stuff and
basically just had to fight them both at
once and then there's another one where
a guy's augmented penis had gone haywire
and you had to rush him to the ripa dock
basically and like there's a whole bunch
of car badging between there and so
that's that's kind of the the world they
trying to set up and it's it's not all
like grim dark cyberpunk stuff there is
a bit of there's a lot of levity in
there I think the most interesting thing
for me is how much the corpo stuff
played into the main quest since my
character came from a corporate
background like there's that whole thing
where one of your contacts
sets you up so it gives you like a like
a credit shift with a virus to like like
sabotage the the Marauders basically we
take the corpo path your character
basically knows all this [ __ ] that she's
gonna pull you can just call her out on
it and just long yeah just basically you
are in the
no power there which I found quite
interesting when I did that I decided to
ignore her completely so the in the
original demos they do that bit where
they go to her get the chip and then go
to the Maelstrom gang and eventually
things kick off so I was like I'm gonna
just ignore that because I want to get
into it as quick as possible
and the first thing I do when I meet
with the bad guy is
oh the gang leader is 2 min ahead and
kill him like straightaway because it's
like you don't have the money to do
anything else or your choices are either
to kill him or get killed and that
knock-on effect is in the original when
you did the kind of corpo route as well
that dude would get away and then come
back later with his exoskeleton and
fight you this time around because he
was dead there was just no one in that
area like there was two gods who are
just like knocked out I was like I'm out
so like there is there's like very
noticeable changes to what happens in a
mission depending on how in my
playthrough I could not focus on the
main path at all like almost every every
corner I turned I was like ooh this
looks interesting and I'd get out and
check it out just because the world is
so dense but I found one small alley
that opened up into this huge
marketplace area where there all these
characters wandering around like it was
packed and there was a guy on the corner
who was like you know he's a sidewalk
creature yelling about how cybernetics
are destroying people in the next
generation needs to stop sigh bring up
their body so they can so they can
continue to live and and whatnot and I
was watching him for a little bit cuz I
was just like yeah sure and to like
trendy looking girls walked up with
phones and immediately started like oh
this is the crazy guy everyone's been
talking about like like let's get some
pictures of them and they start like
taking selfies with him and whatnot and
he just keeps yelling about it and he's
getting frustrated and I'm just sitting
here watching this whole thing play out
it is a very dense and distracting world
and trying to block all that out and
actually look at the city before the
city is like is is very nice like I
really appreciated how today it was
built it's very it's got a lot of
verticality to it there a lot of
and like twisty pathways it's like a lot
of dead areas of the city if you know
what I mean like is there a lot of
freeways intersecting so there's
obviously gonna be the quiet areas of
the city places that are a bit ugly uh
yeah cuz like it it makes the parks are
bustling feel a little more real when
the stuff there's areas that aren't like
I had this one interaction in which
stuck out to me which I'm not sure if it
was an accident but I hope it wasn't but
like I was walking and I kind of drifted
into a area of the pavement where there
was a cop nearby and he did not want me
to be there and he very aggressively
shouted like backup
but next to me was a I'm not body
shaming or anything like that a very
large man was next to me and I don't
know what happened but like he freaked
out I just started running and I was
like okay I'm just gonna follow this guy
and I followed this guy for awhile and
he just kept running and it wasn't like
he was just running in a straight line
he was he looked like he was going
somewhere and I was like I asked the
developer I was like is this does this
dude have a story and he was like I'm
not sure and I wanted to follow him
because he looked terrified and he just
he was like running he's I don't know
how he had that much stamina I was like
if this was if this was like my natural
playthrough I think I would follow him
for about 50 20 minutes just to see what
would happen I think something else I
really stood out stuck out to me was the
brain dance mechanic did you guys try
that I didn't know yeah so that's
something I didn't really know about
I've been kind of limiting how much I
see but like at the risk of being
reductive it's the detective mode
investigations that are from Batman
Arkham origins I like to compare it to
you did you guys play to coma the
follow-up to go yeah that's exactly what
it reminded me of so just having a scene
play out in 3d space but you are free to
move around and look at the other nooks
and crannies not in the main scene so
the idea is people are effectively
taking their memories and recreating
them almost like in a video editing
suite and then selling them on for
various thing most of the time it's used
for you know adult entertainment but you
can do weird things with it and you can
also do things like put yourself into
another person's memory and explore it
and you can do that by a first-person or
you can detach and just watch it okay
out and then there's like wrinkles like
using just focusing on an audio layer in
the actual environment and listening to
key conversations they show you how it
works by making you live through a
failed holdup scene where one person is
where the perpetrator is killed and you
figure out why that happened and how
that happened and it's just really cool
wrinkle that makes me makes me excited
about the potential for likely future
coffee and like the example that they
gave us is obviously very early and very
linear and I kind of am curious to see
whether the story changes based on what
you do or don't pick up like if you go
into a brain dance and don't pick up a
clue what happens then yeah impressive
right
too bad most of the biddies we do here
are only good for flogging my log in a
lot of ways it does feel like an abort
RPG that you know players will probably
very familiar with
yeah and it's more more like in-depth
into which I was by design so like when
I went into the actual like skill tree
menu I was like wow this is a lot and
they were indeed developer that I was on
call was like yeah people kind of felt
like there wasn't a lot of freedom to
create their own kind of girl they have
pockets of like you know cool and body
and you know tech and that kind of stuff
but were they in those there's like
multiple skill trees that have so many
different small options to unlock like
passives and abilities and that kind of
stuff and for those that want it I did
double check and it seemed the developer
on my paper was like you can do a
no-kill run of the game so that's why
I'll be doing well anyway those are our
impressions of cyberpunk 2077 we have a
ton of cyberpunk content planned and
already up so make sure to check all
that stuff out on GameSpot and if you
have any questions for us we will be
doing a Q&A next week where we will
answer your questions so if you have
anything for us please leave them in the
comments below or you can find us on
Twitter and we will try to get to all
those questions next time anyway thank
you so much for watching and we'll see
you later
[Music]
you
[Music]